very briefly I previously told you about
the progressive musical act deep glass
who is promoting their self-titled new
album also called deep glass available
at cdbaby.com and on itunes they did
something amazing which is they
sponsored half a twenty david pakman
show membership and of those twenty
yesterday I told you that seven remained
there are now two of these memberships
left if you want one of these remaining
two half priced yearly memberships they
normally cost $60 deep glass has already
paid for $30 so there's two memberships
left where you pay $30 but you get the
full membership and you get to keep that
price for as long as you want and for
every album sold on cdbaby.com
or through itunes between now and when
the memberships run out three dollars
will be donated to the Institute for
Women's policy research by deep glass so
check out the deep glass self-titled
album on CD Baby and on iTunes and email
me if you want one of the last remaining
two half-price memberships don't assume
someone else will get them because if
everybody does then we'll have two
memberships unspoken for if you have an
interest in it email me and hopefully
you will get that half-price membership